Добрий ранок!
Бігі вітається із Едді, своєю вантажівкою. Вона належить компанії,
але тільки Бігі дозволено керувати нею.
Бірґітте Мош заступає на зміну.
Усього і побільше сюди.
Наступні п'ять днів Бігі їздитиме,
їстиме і спатиме на скромних 5 кв.м салону вантажівки.
Мені просто це подобається. Це...
Я не можу описати мені просто тут дуже добре.
Вона за кермом уже 30 років.
Сьогодні перші 50 км Бігі проїде без причепа.
Дорогою до свого першого вантажу
вона виявляє що під'їздна дорога заблокована.
Чорт забирай!.. Доведеться їхати іншою дорогою.
Чи зможу я тут проїхати? А, я пройду. Чи не пройду...
Тісно. Але Бігі знає свого Едді. Проблему вирішено. Час для наступної.
О, вони вже розвантажуються. Я не можу
під'їхати до свого трейлера.
Трейлер Бігі ліворуч, а інший стоїть праворуч. Проїхати
ніяк.
Я мушу розвернутися і заїхати задом через склад.
Проїхати заднім ходом через склад, повний перешкод, - це дуже тонка робота.
Повільне і точне маневрування, щоб
з'єднатися із причепом.
Сьогоднішній вантаж - спеціальна промислова фарба.
О, Боже мій...
Нічим не гірше за спортзал.
Настав час випити кави. Поки вода закипає, Бігі займається формальностями.
Тут написано: 7:00. А ми були тут раніше 7-ої. Щойно ми закінчили під'єднуватися.
Вона зберігає все для свого роботодавця на бортовому комп'ютері.
Катеріна Боймле, молодша менеджерка компанії, знаходиться у головному офісі.
Бортовий комп'ютер вантажівки дозволяє їй завжди точно знати,
де і коли знаходяться Бігі та Едді.
Тут ви бачите, що минулого понеділка був дуже щільний трафік. Вона могла проїхати всього 4 км за 50 хвилин.
Тому сильно запізнилася. Коли ми бачимо це, то
можемо реагувати і вирішувати що робити далі.
Тобто тут ви можете стежити за всім?
Так.
Для компанії перевізника важливо все відстежувати. Зрештою у них 160 вантажівок на рейсах.
Але їм не вистачає водіїв. Катеріна разом з батьками переглядає нові заявки на роботу.
Молодша менеджерка сподівається найняти більше жінок-водійок.
Взаємини складаються по-різному. Наприклад, у конфліктних ситуаціях, які, сподіваюся, будуть рідкісними, у мене були жінки,
які вибачалися на наступний день, тому що
вони були не в настрої. Таке буває, але не з чоловіками.
Тож, це інша форма взаємин. Та обидві статі можуть виконувати свою роботу однаково добре.
Тим не менш лише троє зі 180 водіїв - жінки.
Бос вважає, що це занадто мало.
Нам загалом потрібно більше людей. Тому ми раді кожній людині, яка приєднується до нас, кому це подобається,
хто бачить цю роботу як покликання. І неважливо, яка їхня стать.
50 кілометрів уже позаду, і перерва на каву Бігі закінчилася.
Їй та Едді час знову вирушати в дорогу.
У цю справу треба вкладати душу і серце. Інакше нічого не вийде.
Я кермую вантажівками не тому, що мушу, а тому що
хочу. Візьміть, наприклад, Едді, мою вантажівку.
Звісно, це вантажівка. Але він також мій напарник. Ми працюємо разом.
Коли йому погано - мені теж погано. Так само як і в партнерстві.
Я одружена зі своєю вантажівкою.
Якби у мене був партнер, який сказав би мені, що я маю покинути цю справу, я б сказала "ні, я не піду, іди геть".
Водіння - це моє життя.
Любов Бігі до водіння коштувала їй двох шлюбів. Це її не турбує.
Але вона глибоко шкодує, що більше не бачить своїх двох доньок.
Я ніколи не була поруч із ними. Лише по телефону. Я ніколи не тримала їх на руках.
Зараз жінка приїхала ближче до своїх доньок. Вона не хоче прогавити ще й можливість бачитися із онуками.
Та це не означає, що вона збирається покинути свою улюблену роботу.
Поки що Бігі та Едді будуть і далі долати кілометри доріг.